okay the the last section of today's lab
is going to apply clustering and
principal components analys PCA methods
to uh to one of the data sets in the in
the islp package so this is a a Micro
Data set and it has the feature that
it's going to be more data than we saw
in our in our earlier examples we we've
only looked at toy data sets um and with
four features for the USA arrests and
you know we generated data for for
clusters as well okay so this data is is
quite a wide Matrix there's 64 cases so
and six roughly 7,000 features um so and
the cases are different types of cancer
yeah these are different tumors and we'
have some biological measurement a micro
Ray measurement on each of the 7,000
different measurements on on each T
tumor so what in clustering here we're
looking to see
whether in terms of these microway
measurements whether different um tumors
are related so we might expect
you know if we knew that what kind of
cancer they were which we do here we
have labels for each of them we might
expect that you know breast cancer tumor
behave similarly within themselves and
Leukemia behaves similarly within
themselves and we're going to try and
see whether that's uh that happens so
often in uh when doing clustering or PCA
um we might have some label that's held
out that we don't use to fit these
unsupervised methods but we can you know
as a at least a visual validation we
often will color points in a principal
component analysis by the label to see
whether it Rec it this PCA analysis
reconstruct um somehow these labels and
there's if if you look around online
there's actually a really nice uh what
is it is it November is that the the
genetics article there's a really nice
coloring of a principal component
analysis of of genetic data in Europe
that reproduces the map of Europe that's
an example of of one of these things um
November I think is the author yes uh
okay moving on
so we have 64 rows and 7,000 features
now if we run
PCA uh well in the USA Data we had four
features and we got four principal
components so you know we might hope
that we'd get 7,000 principal components
uh but of course that's not going to be
possible right so PCA is only going to
give us well the minimum of uh I think
the number of obser ations minus one and
the number of col and the number of
columns of the data so we're going to
get 63 principal components at most yes
yeah we won't have to keep all of them
yes yes of course it could be less the
mathematician
speaks okay so here we have a summary of
the the different uh the the labels so
we can see there there are I think 13
different uh kinds of uh cancer tumors
um and they're broken down some of them
have names that are interpretable to to
to many of us and these are very sort of
specific
ones okay so let's run a PCA on on the
micro Ray data we're going to scale the
data though in this case since all of
the measurements are in the same units
they're all the same kind of assay we
may not need to scale it but just it's
common practice to scale it so we're
going to we're going to continue with
that okay um so let's see
we can uh we can find the the principal
component scores using the the fit
transform method and we're going to
again make a uh a scatter
plot and as I said before um it's common
practice if you have a label uh to
somehow to label the the plots in a in a
this is something like the bip plot we
saw before though I haven't indicated I
haven't added the um the the vectors
here for the the the dire C and fact
that would be pretty dense right there
would be 7,000 vectors or so here so um
oh this is again piece this is the first
and the second and this is the first and
the third and what we're looking at here
is try to get a sense of whether there
is clustering in these principal
components and there's you know these
green ones are in similar location for
the first two there's some evidence of
clustering again the color map um is not
uh it may be not optimal because I can't
actually tell whether this
uh this blue is different from that blue
just by looking at this yeah so probably
best to to make a better color map if
you can um so there is an argument to
the scatter plot that would allow us to
change the color
map okay so let's take a look at the
um the sort of similar plot we saw for
the US ARS data we're going to plot the
percent variance explained and the
cumulative percent variance explained so
remember for the the US ARS data I think
the first one uh the first principal had
60 odd percent of the variants explained
right so here well 15% and that's
actually still quite a lot for 7,000
variables right if was sort of
completely randomly dis spread it would
be you know 1 out of 7,000 or so so now
inevitably if you're going to use these
principal components for more than just
um looking at plots like this you might
use for instance you might use principal
components in regression like we saw in
the end of the the lab in chapter 6
though we didn't cover it in the video
it's it's it's contained in the textbook
um you'll want to choose number of
principal components though for
principal components regression we can
of course choose cross validation but
the way people often choose the number
of components is by looking at a plot
like this this thing is this is called a
scre plot and so um you know people will
look for some break some Bend in an
elbow of this as a as a way way to
choose the number of principal
components though um you know there's a
lot of discussion these days about how
to do this you know in a in a
theoretically Justified way but P
practically speaking but this would Su
or n six yeah something like that yeah
when it as as it's decaying like this
there's not really you know a big
difference between you know there's not
a change in big change in the rate as
you as you in improve increase the
number of components but we don't have I
don't have a theoretic answer for that
but this is just an
eyeballing here we have the first seven
principal components have about 40% of
the variance so that's we can see here
that's about somewhere around
seven okay so after having run PCA on
the this Micro Data we're going to take
a look at clustering and uh as in the
principal components analysis what you
know in a practical sense what we're
looking for is when we plot a a
dendogram say from a clustering at at
and cut it somewhere that looks like a
reasonable cut but what we'd like to see
is that the the corresponding clusters
correspond to the different cancer types
um so we and and this hierarchical
clustering is very popular in the
genomics community because the data is
so big and wide hard to look at it gives
them one way of looking at the data and
became very
popular yes so before we cut uh the the
a dendogram we're just going to compare
the different linkages uh so we're going
to make uh three plots um one for the
complete linkage one for the average
linkage and one for the single
linkage
and let's see I'll just scroll through
the three of them and then I'll come
back just so we can see the difference
so let's this is the complete linkage
and we note there are a few you know few
longish bars so a a bar like this or is
an indication that you know this cluster
it was far away from the next cluster
was merged with if this is really really
long then the cluster a cluster that is
that it emanates from was far from where
the one it was finally emerged to so
that's an indication that uh this is a
good place to to cut the dendogram and
by the way because we know there are
some cancer classes underneath this you
might expect to see a bunch a bunch of
well-defined clusters at the top of this
picture and then not much below and
that's kind of what we see in here yeah
you can see here there's there's a group
here these are the colon Cancers and
they're sort of they kind of correspond
to to this cluster here this group over
here is mostly leukemia and that's kind
of if I cut somewhere around there so
that's what complete linkage look like
and let's look at the other extreme is
single linkage and then I'll go talk
about average so this is single linkage
and compared to complete linkage there's
really no place you know if we cut
anywhere around here we're the results
are going to be very sensitive they're
going to change a lot so there's no
natural break and this is a this is a
common phenomenon in single linkage
called chaining and so what happens is
many of these merges are just adding on
a little bit to a bigger cluster so this
sort of set of like if you look at these
values here these are all merging single
points and quite far along in the
clustering process compared
to um the complete linkage they were
about halfway up the tree when those
single points were merged an average
linkage it unfortunately got a little
cut in the page here but it's sort of in
between the two um there's you know
maybe a few places a few cluster I mean
this range here might might produce some
some some clusters but um it's not
exactly as clear as complete
linkage okay so now we're going to cut
so it looks like if we cut somewhere
around here there are pretty you know
that's a there are some nice looking
clusters that we can see by eye and
we'll color them and then we'll take a
look at the labels to see if we
recovered things like this colon cancer
group and this leukemia cancer okay so
I'm going to cut the
dagram
uh we're going to cut at the level
140 let's shrink a little
bit let's see uh
these purple ones it's rather small but
they seem to be mostly leukemia with the
exception of these two and I I'm not an
expert not to know those might be a form
of leukemia we make it a bit bigger
because we can see the we can see that's
a good point yeah and the these red ones
many it's it's mostly of colon cancer
though a few breast cancers were
included and again I don't really I'm
not certain enough to know what that
what that that type of can cancer is so
this isn't you know perfect this cluster
over here you
know it has a mix maybe majority breast
cancer but not not Surly not pure you
know and unfortunately you know we can't
expect to get perfect separation into
classes unless you know there was a
really really strong difference well
also remember we had there were 13
different types of cancer years so by
picking cutting and having four groups
we necessarily emerging some that's a
good point so what you like to see is
say for example in the green you know
that there's merging of some cancer
classes but but these cancer claes don't
spread into other clusters yeah so I get
there is a subcluster maybe
here Reno but um yes yeah that's a good
point with only four we can never get
all 13 um and also we only had 64
subjects so to really distinguish the
cancer types you if we probably need
more subjects than that especially
because we have 7,000 measurements on
each um so that's an example of uh two
places where unsupervised methods um
might be used the remainder of the lab
um also does K means clustering on the
on this on this data but as we mentioned
before Hier clustering is is sort of
most more commonly applied to this kind
of data set so we're going to leave that
for you uh to do
offline